o pessoal seja bem-vindo é mais um vídeo
e este vídeo não é patrocinado mas a
neve quiser patrocinar meu site sem
problema nenhum ok então o seguinte e
hoje voa abril estarão que já abrigou
mostrar pra vocês e vou fazer alguns
disparos e protestou gravar esposa então
só está muito aprovada está a noite para
duas balas e tem uma precisão muito boa
e parei mais ou menos daqui eu seja 45
metros mas foi só com uma mão e uma
coisa é quando você usa uma arma não é
vocês não urbana é muito contou
declararam que tentei ficar fixo porque
se vocês abanarem quando a bola for sair
ela bate nestas coisas mudam curinga
direção que é o sustento para vocês foi
ar é isso então só manter bem fix e é
bacana porque esta parte encosta mesmo
na mão então vocês conseguem estabilizar
e tem aquela coisa pra vocês porém das
bolas e que traz só que ela só vem com
duas balas então que todas as armas vêm
com um número exato de balas que armas
para que uma equipe pelo pouparem balas
nem pra gente tem como comprar depois
então vou pensar comprar depois por aqui
e fazer as coisas de frente de coma e
cinematográfico assim fazer fogo e tal
depois que vocês vão ver é mais uma das
coisas que eu vou comprar esta arma
também é que vai uma impressora 3d
caminho e eu quero abrir as armas que eu
tenho da en3 e ver como funciona o
sistema lá dentro e depois vou tentar
modular no computador
vou mandar a impressora para fazer as
pecinhas e vou tentar fazer a minha
própria arma nuclear que vai ser mais
simples no início é importante é que ela
dispara eu estou bastante ansioso para
experimentar
embora agora o brilho é capaz de mostrar
como ela era antes e depois fazer um
despacho
o pessoal espera de um estadista se
vocês quiserem mais é podem deixar os
comentários porque sofri bastante links
então eu vou trazer mais um vídeo do ar
mais leve é porque não custa nada e eu
gosto bastante então estamos fazendo é
isso então tchau
foi assim com um bis em branco no caso
foi assim